- Elle est un visage connu,
à Kahnawake.
(en anglais)
"Je savais que tu allais
gagner", lance un résident
à Kahsennehawe Sky-Deer pendant
notre entrevue. À 41 ans,
elle devient la première femme
à occuper le poste de grande
cheffe de la communauté mohawk.
(en anglais)
"C'était émouvant", dit-elle
de la soirée d'élection
qui s'est tenue samedi.
Son collègue Mike Delisle,
lui-même grand chef de 2004
à 2015, salue son arrivée
au pouvoir.
(en anglais)
La communauté a envoyé
le message qu'elle est prête
pour du changement.
Kahsennehawe Sky-Deer a de
l'expérience, fait-il valoir.
Elle s'implique au sein
du Conseil Mohawk depuis 2009.
Elle succède à Joe Norton,
décédé en août dernier,
tête dirigeante de Kahnawake
pendant près de 30 ans.
(en anglais)
La nouvelle grande cheffe
a grandi ici-même. Elle a quitté
le nid familial pour jouer
au football professionnel
en Floride au début des années
2000. Elle a d'ailleurs obtenu
un baccalauréat en psychologie
aux États-Unis, avant de revenir
à la maison.
Parmi ses priorités, elle
souhaite unir la communauté
et apaiser la douleur causée
par la découverte de restes
d'enfants sur les terrains
d'anciens pensionnats
autochtones.
Déjà, elle aura brisé
le plafond de verre, et de plus
d'une façon : elle est aussi
membre de la communauté LGBTQ+,
la première à devenir grande
cheffe.
Ce qui est important, dit-elle,
ce n'est pas son sexe ni avec
qui elle est mariée, mais plutôt
sa contribution à sa communauté.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, K